一つめちゃくちゃ疑問に思ったことがありまして
一つめちゃくちゃ疑門
ハンドソープ
こういうよくあるハンドソープなんですけども
ポンプ式のハンドソープって一回押したら泡が出るんですけども
回数が書いてないんですよ・・・
入ってる量は書いてるんですけども
はたして何回ポンプ
何回ポンプをすることができるのかっていうのが書いてないので
だからね、わかんないんですよねこれ一個買って何日間持つかとか
どれくらいで変えたらいいのかっていうのがちょっとわかんないんで
今回はこちらのハンドソープ4種類を準備して
はたしてこいつたちは何回ポンプ
プッシュすることができるのかっていうの今回検証していこうと思います
これ何がわかるかといいますと
これ4つあってもどれが何回使っ
これ、
でかいな
いやわかんない、それはわかんない
この4つが何回ポンプすることができるかっていうのを調べることのよって
どれを買えば一番長持ちするのかっていうのがわかります
画期的でしょ！
これで一番ポンプできたやつを買えば長持ちするから
間違いないっす！！
ちょっともったいないかも知れないんですけどもこうしないとわかんないから
こうしないと誰が誰だか・・・
誰が誰だかはわかります
こうしないと誰が長持ちするかっていうのがわかんないんで
今日は！！
ハンドポンプをポンプして！
はたして！！
誰が！！
一番！！
長持ちするか！！
誰が！！
一番！！
ポンプ！！
できるか！！
調べて！！
行こうと思います！！
選手入場！
ビオレのハンドソープ
まあ、これも結構人気というか有名ですよね
250ミリリットル入っています
マツモトキヨシで買ったハンドソープ
あんまり見たことないんですけども300ミリリットル入ってます。一番多い
この絵が結構好きです。キレイキレイ
キレイキレイも結構有名ですよね
キレイキレイが250ミリリットル入ってます
最後、こちら
ピングーが書いてあります。ウォシュボン
ウォシュボンは！！
ウォシュボンは、
あーーーーーーーーーーーーーー
Two thousand eighty （280ミリリットル）
これが300ミリリットル、２８０、２５０、２５０
これ優勝！！
一番多いのが優勝すると思うんですけども、おそらくわかんないんですよ
ポンプがどのくらいその、ハンドソープを吸い上げるかによってまた戦いが変わってくるんで
では量っていこうと思います
まずビオレから、行きまーす
今のはノーカウントで
出てからカウントしますからね
２、けっこうでるな
９６、９７，９８、９９、１００
１９８、１９９、２００、あ、200はいけますね
３０１、３０２、あー苦しい３０３、あ～～～～
３１６、３１７、３１８あ、もうこれだめだな
３２０くらいです！
320ということは一日一プッシュつかったとしても、11ヶ月弱くらいはもつは持つくらいな感じです
次はこちらキレイキレイ行ってみましょう
中の量同じなので320回超えれるか超えれないかが勝負になって来ると思います
１、めっちゃ飛ぶ
９５，９６，９７、９８，９９、１００
１９８、１９９、２００、200行きました。２０２，２０３、２０４、２０５
８８，８９、９０
あー！！あー！！あー！！あー！！
あー！！
あーぉ！！
９５、あー！！
９７（きゅうじゅうなな）
アー！！
９７（きゅうじゅうしち）
あー！！
ああ！！！
あーもうでてないっすねこれは
303かーーーい
303回か・・・
多いのか少ないわかんない
ただビオレのほうが出ることがわかりました
泡のね勢いが強かったんでその分多分体力を使うタイプだな
このウォシュボンってやつ使ってみようと思います
これ280（ミリリットル）なんで、
この二つよりかは30ミリリットル多い
こっちの方が300回軽く超える気がしますね
200ゥウ！！
２９３、２９４，２９５
もうくるしいか！？
３１４、あーくるしい！！
アウトーーーーー！！！
フィニーーーーーッシュ！！！！
はい、ウォシュボン316回でございます
思ったより少ないか？
あぁなんか持ち手みたいになっちゃった
全然量多いのにあんまり変わんなかったっすね
はい、というわけで次が本命です
マツモトキヨシの泡ハンドソープ
内容量的には一番多いですね
これが300ミリリットル
いやぁこれまあ400回くらい行かないとだめでしょ
では早速やっていこうと思います
いきまーす！！！！！
いきなりでるのね
２９８，２９９
違う
さんびゃくほちゃーわーわんわーー　あはぁーーらー
３３７！！
３５０、３５１ああーーーー！！
終、うぅぉおええええ
優勝！！
ちょっともったいないんで再利用しよう
待ってこれで今日体洗おうかな
これで今日体洗おう
ちょ、まじやべえまじやべえ
あーまあ、あーなんか
あーちょっ
あー
あー！！！
ちょっとしみる！！！